president Donald Trump's feud with
congressional Democrats just crossed
international boundaries with two
Democratic House members planning a trip
to Israel and the occupied West Bank
Trump urged Israel to ban them from
entry they are very anti-jewish and
they're very anti-israel I think it's
disgraceful the things they've said and
they've become the face of the Democrat
Party I can't imagine why Israel would
let them in a Thursday morning tweet to
that effect from Trump is apparently all
it took for Israel to reverse its
earlier position barring Ilhan Omar and
Rashida Talib from entering the country
Israel's Prime Minister cited their
support of a boycott of Israel we are
not willing to admit into Israel those
who call for the boycott of the State of
Israel and act to be legitimized the
state of the Jews Trump's successful
effort to pressure Israel is the latest
salvo in his battle with the squad for
democratic women of color in Congress
Ilhan omar fired back saying it is an
affront that Israeli Prime Minister
Netanyahu under pressure from President
Trump would deny entry to
representatives of the US government
Trump's Muslim ban is what Israel is
implementing this time against - duly
elected members of Congress there's a
long-standing tradition in u.s. politics
that however contentious things are at
home US presidents do not enlist allies
abroad to target political opponents but
Trump has never been bound by
conventional politics the president has
said the four members of the squad
should go back to their countries even
though three of them were born here in
the US that hasn't stopped crowds at his
rallies from chanting send her back the
unprecedented ban on two members of the
US Congress was widely condemned by
Democrats and Republicans in Congress
alike by the Palestine Liberation
Organization this is really unacceptable
it's a direct answer
does that American people even the
pro-israel American Israel Public
Affairs Committee joined in saying in a
statement that while the group disagrees
with the Congress women every member of
Congress should be able to visit an
experience or a democratic ally Israel
firsthand with both Trump and Netanyahu
facing upcoming elections the temptation
to team up against a common adversary
was apparently too great to pass up john
Hendren al jazeera washington